MICHEL DEGRAFF: So
I start the class.
On the very first day,
while they are still
fresh and unsuspecting
of the class contents,
of my own ideology, I
give them a survey where
I ask very simple questions.
You know, their
major, their year.
But I also ask them
personal questions.
Where were they born?
Where did they travel?
And during what years?
They were in which parts of
the country or the world?
And I asked them about some
of the course contents.
You know, what do they know
about Creole languages?
How they define identity.
What does identity mean?
What kind of images
does the word Caribbean
trigger in their minds?
So, very easy
questions to answer.
But through these questions,
I'm able to see and to get
a sense of both the
personal background,
but also what kind
of assumptions
they bring to the course.
And then I can use that to
kind of have a beginning where
I can address these fundamental
assumptions that they do bring
in the course, and also
to connect the discussion
to the personal profiles.
And then as we progress,
I can, from time to time,
check to see how some of the
ideas might have mutated,
might have evolved
through our discussions.
So it's a nice
benchmark to start with.